okay let's jump into uh audience
questions for the week first question is
david we know joe biden is polling quite
well
from a standpoint of approval but why
isn't kamala harris nearly as popular as
joe biden so i didn't even know about
this i looked into it and it's true
kamala harris approval rating is quite a
bit lower uh economist yougov poll
has about 51 approval for joe biden only
41
approval for kamala harris lower
certainly outside of the margin of error
um in a more recent poll um
uh harris was at 26 very favorable with
joe biden 33 at very favorable there is
a gap
it's not a massive gap and given that
i don't find it hugely surprising that
kamala harris is not polling as well as
joe biden for a few different reasons
first of all she was never as popular as
joe biden during the primaries there was
a period there
i think when she had that bomb drop
moment about biden being racist or
something during
a debate where she gained a little bit
and then she very quickly
within a couple of weeks lost that and
she was never super popular
so unless there's some reason why she
would now be very popular
it's not surprising to me that she's not
doing super well
uh as far as approval the second piece
of it is
joe biden often talks about the biden
harris administration
and kamala harris is often there at
different things but she's not
been particularly present as a major
player in a lot of the things that are
what makes joe biden popular today i'm
not saying she wasn't a major player i'm
saying it just hasn't been
apparent from much of the way that the
stories have been covered covet stimulus
for example it really
was framed as this is biden negotiating
and then democrats in the house and
senate getting it done and harris is
there you know in the room as has often
been said
but she's not sufficiently connected to
it and then
lastly there is a kind of personality
aspect which is as the vice president
she hasn't taken the spotlight uh now
some may say well she's not been allowed
to that may be i'm not saying
that she's chosen not to i'm saying she
hasn't been in the spotlight and that
means that the discourse
is sort of happening around her more
than being shaped by
her actions herself now there's one last
thing on and it's sort of a
propagandistic thing
we've talked about how um the
republican party and right-wing media
and others have concocted the
immigration crisis the crisis at the
border
now the truth is things aren't much
different at the border than they were
under donald trump
uh they've gotten significantly better
actually in the last six weeks which
we've reported on but
uh the the narrative has been it's a
border crisis
and it worked in that back in june only
28
of the country thought there was a
crisis at the border last month
48 of the country believed there was a
crisis at the border so the propaganda
has worked how does this relate to
kamala
it relates to kamala harris because she
was
designated as the person who was going
to
handle the situation at the border now
if you believe it's a crisis and you
believe what fox news says that
nothing's been done
and you remember that it was assigned to
kamala harris
you probably don't have a particularly
high view
of favorable view of kamala harris so i
think that the negativity around that
probably
is not is not helping her either that's
my sense
never really popular to begin with not
in the spotlight for
joe biden's successes and i don't want
to say thrown under the bus
but tied to a
fabricated so-called crisis at the
border
because it was assigned to her portfolio
and the right-wing media narrative is
just that the crisis continues
regardless of what the truth is there
send me your thoughts if you have a
different view
as to why kamala's approval is lower
than than biden's and last thing
i think generally the vice president has
a lower approval than the president
i think it was the case with mike pence
and donald trump for most of his
presidency correct me if i'm wrong i'm
going from memory
um it doesn't strike me as shocking for
that reason either
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video